This is my whole world:...
...my nurse, my mom, my sickness.
I'm 18 and I've never been outside.
If I did, I would probably die.
He's here.
Who's here?
You're really different than I thought you were gonna be.
Sexier, right?
What would happen if you went outside?
Probably spontaneous combustion.
Here I have HEPA filters, outside it's viruses and bacteria.
Where would you go if you could?
The ocean.
I've never seen it.
Dear mom,...
I know staying in this house keeps me alive, but this isn't living.
I want to experience everything.
Everything.
Maddy, what are you doing?
Go back inside.
No! Olly, I have to know if I'm really sick...
...and the only way that I'll know is if I'm outside.
I'm willing to sacrifice everything just to live one perfect day.